when you won the Oscar in uh syriana the
thing that fascinated me and I didn't
know this you got injured on that Set uh
oh yeah you hurt you hurt your spine
right there was a scene where a chair
gets knocked over you're tied up to a
chair and gets knocked over and what is
it that medically that happened that
that you were in so much pain because
your spine
your spinal fluid was the it's really
something crazy what is that you have a
thing that wraps your spine called the
dura it's like a Saran wrap around your
spine and your spine holds all the
spinal fluid in it but spinal fluid is
also what your brain sits in yeah it's
your brain floats right in your head
well maybe not in all of our heads but
not mine some of our heads you know
right your brain floats and it's held up
by sort of the pressure of you know the
spinal fluid and uh and I fell over and
I tore my spine and my Dura in two
places you know about an inch and a half
and one and you know a half an inch in
the other and all the spinal fluid goes
out and your brain
sinks in your head and it's attached to
all these nerve endings and it's really
unbearably painful and you have to lay
down and you can't get up and it's I
thought I had a stroke honestly and I
you know I thought well I'm stuck and we
finally got to a doctor I had to get on
the plane and get back to a doctor I
went to a doctor and I had spinal fluid
coming out of my nose I thought I'd
signed a horrible sinus infection or
something happened and spinal fluid was
coming out my nose and he goes oh I know
what it is and then they had to do I did
a 12 hour surgery on Christmas Eve you
always worry about the doctor you get on
Christmas Eve right that's not the time
you want to go right it should have been
a one-hour surgery yeah um no I got a
12-hour surgery and then you know
wrapped it up and I had to do these
things called blood patches where they
patch it up all the time and I did that
with the pain the pain of something like
that you must have been going out of
your mind I mean you've said the pain
was so bad I considered suicide it was
so intense the pain it was wrecking your
life but it wasn't suicide like oh I I'm
you know uh woe is me in a way it was
more like I I just felt like
I can't possibly survive like this I
can't you know I started by taking you
know you're taking a lot of painkillers
and those are that's a slippery slope
man you know and they'll hand you the
tub of Vicodin like this right and you
know you take one and you're like and
you take a second one and then you take
a glass of wine and you're like
this shit's pretty good right and then
you know after after a couple of months
or a month I guess of that I was like
I'm gonna be in real trouble here with
this so I had to just flush them all
down the toilet and then I went to this
pain management guy
really fascinating cat who his idea was
he said look you have to rethink pain
which is a funny thing he said rethink
it in the sense that if you were born
feeling the way you feel right now you
wouldn't know you were in pain you would
think this is exactly how you're
supposed to feel this is normal because
so you have to because so in a way the
pain you're experiencing is mourning for
the way that you used to feel right so
you have to readjust your pain threshold
to go this is normal
and think of it that way and then
everything will get better and it did
foreign